new polling from the New York Times of
all places suggests the Democrats have
been living in a progressive fantasy
world if they believe that they are
likely to defeat President Trump in 2020
which makes sense if Democrats believe
other fantasies like the narrative the
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself we will
examine how the left can be so gullible
when nobody believes the press then an
ex evangelical pastor who left his
church family and faith is lecturing
evangelicals on how they're ruining
Christianity finally the mayor of tent
city Los Angeles claims with a straight
face that LA is the model city for
dealing with homelessness all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
la is the model city for dealing with
homelessness just like Krispy Kreme is
the model company for dealing with
obesity we'll get to that unbelievable
that they can say this that's the whole
theme people say with a straight face
narratives and storylines that nobody
actually believes beginning with
probably the biggest storyline the most
ridiculous narrative the craziest
wildest conspiracy theory of the last
several years the idea that Jeffrey
Epstein was just like randomly permitted
to kill himself nobody actually believes
that right there is a former Navy SEAL
who went on Jesse Watters his show on
Fox News and he was talking about
military dogs because of the story of
Conan that dog who chased down Abu Bakr
al Baghdadi so it's a completely nice
normal segment about military dogs and
then at the end he just sneaks in a
little bit of a fact and a little bit of
a meme which is that Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself well thank you for
training Nero
whose to your left there and I'm sure
he's ready to go out on the next mission
and he can't wait so thank you and thank
Nero for your service I appreciate it
absolutely if I could could I throw a
PSA out real quick real quick just the
the remarkable nature of these dogs and
them being highlighted in the news
creates a huge demand by people that
frankly shouldn't have them if if you
see the the coverage and you decide I
want one of these dogs either by a
finished trained you know fully trained
and finished dog from a professional or
just just don't get one at all that and
Epstein didn't kill himself
alright okay thank you for that
commentary all right the greatest fox
news guests in all of history i say this
with no false modesty i've been a guest
on fox news a hundred times and probably
closer to 200 times this man is the
greatest fox news guest ever i bow down
to you sir really really well done
totally straight face and then he slips
in this line also Jeffrey Epstein didn't
kill himself what he's saying is not
just something that we all believe to be
true he's saying an internet meme
this has become a meme to just give a
narrative state a number of random facts
maybe historical facts and then at the
end as a non-sequitur say also Jeffrey
Epstein didn't kill himself
or even you try to fit it in so you can
tie it in so for instance yesterday I
tweeted out I said on this day six
hundred eight years ago Khalil Sultan
the Tim Reid ruler of transoxiana died
at the age of 27 shortly thereafter his
wife committed suicide which
distinguishes her from Jeffrey Epstein
who did not kill herself
this has been going around the internet
for several days now and it's not just
that it's very funny it's that these
memes do tell us something about the
culture and the media so another one
that was going around oh I also tweeted
out I said that L is for the way you
look at me o is for the only one I see V
is very very extraordinary E is for the
fact that Epstein didn't kill himself
another one was a just a block of text
it said if I have to see one more
Jeffrey Epstein meme I'm literally gonna
kill myself
unlike Epstein who is obviously murdered
another one a fun fact the topaz
hummingbird is the smallest bird in the
world even though it has the smallest
bird brain in existence it knows that
Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself and
then this one might be my favorite
the babby Russa is a wild pig whose
tusks can grow so long they curve
backwards ultimately impaling their
skulls and accidentally killing them
unlike Jeffrey Epstein who was killed on
purpose why are the memes so popular why
did this guy go on Fox News and put that
in at the end of his segment two reasons
there are exactly two reasons for this I
will tell you both of those reasons in
one second but first I've got to thank
our friends over at zip recruiter hiring
can be a very slow arduous brutal
process Cafe Alto is co o Dillon Miska
wits needed to hire a director of coffee
for his organic coffee company he was
having trouble finding qualified
applicants so he turned to zip recruiter
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you this is the key
zip recruiter finds the candidates
for you you know old hiring technology
is basically like taking a big handful
of spaghetti and you just throw it at
the wall and you try to see what sticks
that's not a zip recruiter works we're
living in the 21st century act like it
in its technology identifies people with
the right experience if then invites
them to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast Dylan posted
his job on zip recruiter he said he was
impressed by how quickly he had great
candidates apply he then used sip
recruiters candidate rating feature to
filter his cap applicants so that he
could just focus on the most relevant
ones and that's how Dylan found his new
director of coffee in just a few days
obviously here at the Michael Nolt show
we need to find directors of cafe pretty
regularly because we just got to keep it
going through our veins you got to use
if recruiter when you want to do that
with results like that it is no wonder
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within just the first day super
important so right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash Knowles can awl es that is
zip recruiter dot-com slash Knowles
canna wles zip recruiter comm slash
Knowles why are the Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself means so popular two
reasons one we can't trust the
mainstream media two we can't trust the
mainstream media those are the two
reasons they're actually different what
do I mean the media tell us that it was
a suicide
we know that the media are in bed with
politicians we know that the media are
in bed with some of Jeffrey Epstein's
clients and staff members we know that
corporate interests play a role in the
media as well we know that the
mainstream media have abdicated their
duty as journalists and so we can't rely
on them to tell the truth actually James
O'Keefe just showed this today in a
breaking story about Jeffrey Epstein
we'll get to that in one second so the
first reason is we can't trust the
mainstream media to give us the straight
news the other reason that the memes are
popular is that we can't trust the
mainstream media and therefore we need
to turn to means because memes beat the
mainstream media
beat the mainstream media because
they're a way to spread information
outside the traditional bounds of the
traditional press this was hugely
effective in 2016
President Trump was of the meme king he
didn't start this he just because he's a
product of the popular culture because
he's extraordinarily good at
manipulating the media he became part of
this organic grassroots media campaign
that used internet memes Elizabeth
Warren right now is trying to capture
this same thing and it's not working
she's got her own meme team not gonna
work never gonna work she's not built
for memes why not because the mainstream
media love Elizabeth Warren the whole
thing about memes is they've got to be
countercultural the whole thing about
counterculture is it's got to constantly
use changing lingo it's got to be
subversive it has to be unapproved
it can't be the main storyline being
pushed by the media liz warren has
cheerleaders everywhere from the major
news outlets all the way to Saturday
Night Live
so the memes are never gonna catch on
for her but they will for Donald Trump
this was a major joke in 2016 is you had
this comparison at an image of CNN or
you know the kind of corporate media and
it said who do you think would win in a
fight the establishment press deep state
federal bureaucracy international
corporate interests and it had a photo
of Alex Jones it said or a shirtless
vitamin salesman screaming on the radio
and it turns out Alex Jones because
Trump won and Jones was considered one
of the deplorable people who was backing
Donald Trump and that's hilarious and
that actually became a meme in and of
itself the memes are not just for
entertainment the memes are actually an
effective way to spread information and
to subvert a mainstream media that is
totally corrupt I did a speech for ya
fat us see this bro a month or so ago
called the mainstream media or fake news
I just outlined very briefly some of the
connections between the press and the
Democratic Party and the mainstream left
and the deep state and the bureaucracy
in the government the speech was like
40min
long and I didn't even come close to
describing all of the connections
it is totally corrupted from within now
James O'Keefe investigative independent
journalist actually has some new
recordings on the epstein affair he got
a hot mic from ABC News anchor amy
robach who was describing how for three
years she tried to report on the Epstein
story she had information on it and her
bosses at ABC News killed the story I've
had the story for three years I've had
this interview with Virginia Roberts we
would not put it on the air first of all
I was told who's Jeffrey Epstein no one
knows who that is this is a stupid story
then the palace found out that we had
her whole allegations about Prince
Andrew and threatened us a million
different ways we were so afraid we
wouldn't be able to interview Kate and
will that we that also quashed the story
and then and then Alan Dershowitz was
also implicated in because of the planes
up she told me everything she had
pictures she had everything she was in
hiding for 12 years we convinced her to
come out we convinced her to talk to us
it was unbelievable what we had Clinton
we had everything I for three years to
get it on to no avail and now it's all
coming out and it's like these new
relevant revelations and I freaking had
all of it I I'm just so pissed right now
like every day I get more and more
pissed cuz I'm just like oh my god we it
wasn't what we had was unreal other
women backing it up hey yep
Brad Edwards the Attorney three years
ago saying like aunt like we there will
come a day when we will realize Jeffrey
Epstein was the most prolific pedophile
this country has ever known and I have
it all three years ago she had it all
three years ago and her bosses wouldn't
let her run it so this is a hot mic
she's obviously complaining to I don't
know her producer or somebody on the set
about how the Epstein story broke and
she could have broke it three years ago
and her job is to break stories that
would have been very helpful to her
professionally and the story got killed
did the story get killed because oh
nobody knows who Jeffrey Epstein is no
of course not the point of the news is
to break the news is to do
investigations and
dig up stories that people haven't heard
about and then convey those stories but
that's not what they did said oh it
doesn't matter it's not a big deal did
they shut it down for that reason or did
they shut it down because of very very
powerful people
perhaps in ABC News insisted that they
shut it down because it wouldn't look
good for them
certainly the latter and so now you have
this meme Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill
himself and the reaction of the
mainstream media the reaction of people
in the establishment is to say oh don't
say that's ridiculous don't traffic in
that sort of nonsense that's a
conspiracy theory maybe but what ABC
News and the rest of the mainstream
media did by covering up the story for
three years he's an actual conspiracy so
forgive us for trafficking in a
conspiracy theory when we have hard
evidence that you guys actually engaged
in a conspiracy I said this when the
Epstein story broke I said I don't know
how Jeffrey Epstein died he very well
might have killed himself what I do know
though is that the least plausible
explanation for how Jeffrey Epstein died
is that he just accidentally was
permitted to kill himself because he he
shouldn't have been able to do it anyway
he tried to kill himself apparently six
days earlier he was then taken off of
suicide watch where he was taken off it
tried to kill himself a couple weeks
earlier he's taken off his suicide watch
six days later then at the time that he
allegedly killed himself both of the
guards who were supposed to check on him
just fell asleep coincidentally at
exactly the same time and then not one
but two cameras outside of his cell just
just didn't work they just malfunctioned
at exactly the same time and then he it
was revealed in the autopsy had a couple
bones few bones broken in his neck that
only appear in about 1% of hangings and
certainly not from a height at which he
would have had to hang himself with his
bed and it was much more in line with
strangulation but hey listen don't ask
any of those questions
don't ever traffic in that kind of crazy
conspiracy theory just ignore the actual
conspiracy of the mainstream media this
is
why the memes work and I've got a big
warning here for the left if the left
wing does not shape up if the left does
not stop spreading lies if the left does
not stop covering up stories on the
mainstream media through its outlets
through its establishment candidates
it's gonna lose again
it's gonna lose again in 2020 without
question because the more corrupt the
mainstream media becomes the more
empowered everybody else feels to spread
their own information and to believe
their own information and there is a lot
of fake information on the Internet
there's that famous picture of Abraham
Lincoln and the quote says don't believe
everything you read on the Internet
Abraham Lincoln 1860 there's a lot of
false information on the Internet
in a in an honest culture in a culture
where the media are actually reporting
the facts people have no need to believe
whatever they read on the internet but
in a culture where ABC News CBS News
let's not forget cheryl atkinson great
investigative reporter cheryl atkinson
had to leave CBS News because her bosses
kept killing stories on Obama's
corruption where the New York Times The
Washington Post are just shamelessly
spreading lies every single day in that
culture people have to believe what they
read on the internet because they have
nowhere else to turn
we'll get into what this means for 20/20
in a second but first I've got to thank
our friends over at Rock Auto you know
me you know I'm not exactly the most
hands-on kind of mechanic active fixer
upper guy in the world okay I don't know
very much about fixing up my house I
certainly don't know anything about
fixing up my car so what I do is when my
car breaks down I go to the auto parts
store and I say okay I don't know I need
the doohickey for though whatever
underneath the hood and then the auto
parts store never has the part all they
do is then they go on the internet and
they look up the part and then they
charge me a huge markup to get the car
part you don't need to do any of that
because you can go to Rock Auto comm
Rock Auto is a family business serving
Auto Parts customers online for 20 years
go to Rock Auto comm to shop for auto
and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers you know
recently my car broke down halfway on
the way up to San Francisco and I'm
dealing with all these mechanics and
they're going online getting the parts I
was complaining about this at the office
and they tell me oh you could have gone
to Rock Auto and now we have Rock Auto
on the show and that'll be what I do
from from now on they have everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
it's for your daily driver you can get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
you get it delivered directly to your
door The Rock Auto dot-com catalog is
unique it is remarkably easy to navigate
you can just see all the parts available
for your vehicle and choose the brand
specifications and prices you prefer
this website is even navigable by me and
I don't know anything about cars but I
know what I need and it's probably as
far as I'm concerned other than the very
very fair pricing the best feature of
Rock Auto and other than the fact that
it's a family-owned business and other
than the fact that they have a great
track record the best feature is it's so
easy to get the part you need on the
website go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right Knowles Canon W in there how
did you hear about us box and that way
they will know that we sent you and that
would be very good rockauto.com fill-out
Knowles in the how did you hear about us
so now james o'keefe actually has new
recordings on the epstein affair we
actually see the mainstream media lying
and admitting they're lying and just
going exposing the conspiracy of the
conspiracy of the conspiracy theory what
does this mean for president Trump it's
good news the more the media look
foolish
the less people are going to believe
what the media tell us the media told us
in 2016 that there was a hundred and
twenty thousand percent chance that
Hillary would win 0% chance the Trump
would win there's no reason even to go
to the polls we heard that the day
before the election I kid you not 99%
chance Hillary wins ninety-seven percent
chance that Hillary wins all the
scientists who allegedly say that global
warming is going to kill us all I guess
they all went and they were the only
people polled and they all voted for
Hillary
so 97% of people gonna vote raillery and
then it didn't happen then Trump won and
we decided maybe we're not gonna believe
the media and yet now for the past few
weeks we've been hearing more and more
polls Trump is gonna lose the majority
of people support impeachment the
majority of people across America want
to elect Joe Biden Fox News of all
places had a poll out that showed that
not only is Biden leading a 2020
Democratic presidential primary race
he's beating Trump in a head-to-head
matchup by 12 points Wow it's like the
race is already over Trump should start
packing his bags right head on down to
Mara Lago which is now going to be his
primary residence we were told that
Bernie Sanders has an eight-point lead
on Donald Trump in a head-to-head
matchup 49 to 41 Elizabeth Warren has a
five-point lead over president Trump 46
to 41 now that's within the polls margin
of error but still Hill or Warren well
that was a Freudian slip I said Hillary
instead of Warren gosh that tells you a
lot about the campaign she's still
beating Trump Pete muda jej is even tied
with Trump boo to judge mayor of a small
town and then Hillary Clinton actual
Hillary Clinton not Elizabeth Warren
Hillary 2.0 but Hillary one point now if
Hillary got into the race according to
this Fox News poll she has a two-point
edge she would beat Trump by two points
so it's all over right no the New York
Times has another poll out that doesn't
just look at the national landscape
because I'm skeptical of all polls as
you know I'm very very skeptical of
national polls because it's turned out
that some of these polls have been
seriously over sampling Democrats but
the polls that I start to get a little
more interested in or the state polls
because the election is not based on
popular vote it's not the United people
of America the United States of America
so the elections are done in the state
level and specifically a handful of
states the battleground states are going
to determine the presidential election
so the New York Times drilled down into
these battleground states and they
realized something horrifying for the
left which is that when you look at the
stay
that are going to decide the election
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin Florida
Arizona North Carolina things are
looking a lot tighter there doesn't
matter if the Democratic nominee wins by
50 points in California or New York the
Democrats gonna win California in New
York what matters are these battleground
states when you look in the battleground
states is Biden's up 12 points on Trump
no he's up 1 or 2 points in all states
but North Carolina where a president
Trump is actually up 2 points so they're
in a dead heat in all the battleground
states
about Bernie Bernie is up three points
in Michigan on Trump head-to-head bernie
is tied with Trump in Wisconsin Trump is
up everywhere else in the battleground
states how about Elizabeth Warren Trump
beats the Elizabeth Warren head-to-head
in every battleground state
how about Pete Budaj edge give me a
break people who did you eat anything or
register Trump is up on everybody by the
way Trump is up on Liz Warren in the
battleground states before she rolled
out her ridiculous medicare-for-all plan
which is going to be extraordinarily
unpopular 52 trillion dollars not
exactly gonna play in Peoria
certainly not in these more moderate
States Trump is a how about in Iowa
Iowa's one of these kind of bellwether
states Trump is up on every candidate in
Iowa the New York Times is actually the
outlet now who's saying hold on a second
don't get too excited don't feel like
you can just nominate the furthest left
candidate don't watch out maybe let's
not go all the way in for Liz Warren
just yet hold on a second but nobody's
paying attention because the left is
living in this fantasy world the fantasy
world in which they believe that they
can just tell you what reality is going
to be and thereby force reality into
existence this is what every one of
these grand poobahs that the mainstream
media networks thinks they say we don't
need to cover the news we are not
beholden to reality we are not going to
be on
stewards of reality and convey that to
the people we are going to in our own
imaginations right the news and by
virtue of our narrative we will force
that unreality that's the opposite of
what the press is supposed to do and the
New York Times which has been in the
press for a long time is beginning to
say gosh
I don't that didn't work out for us in
2016 maybe it's not gonna work out for
us in 2020 Satan it's you're seeing the
same thing now with the the leading
Democratic candidate Joe Biden do you
remember the whole problem with Joe
Biden is that he engaged in some serious
corruption he looks a lot like he
engaged in serious corruption his son
was engaging in corruption and the press
has been telling us there's nothing
there's no evidence of it Joe Biden has
been lying through his teeth
demonstrable lies in just the past few
days said he never knew his son was on
the board of that energy company in
Ukraine even though his son admitted
that they talked about it said they his
son did nothing wrong even though his
son just resigned from the board
basically said I did nothing wrong and
I'm sorry and I'll never do it again now
we have new information about this
corruption we have new information out
that the energy company that Joe Biden's
son sat on the board of had did in fact
push the Obama administration to end its
corruption investigations in 2016 we'll
get to that in a second we'll get to the
effect of impeachment on that race then
an ex evangelical pastor is lecturing
other evangelical zhh about how terrible
they are for supporting the Republican
president we'll get to that kind of
hypocrisy Eric Garcetti mayor of tent
city Los Angeles says that la is the
model for dealing with homelessness and
so much more we have to get to but first
I've got to say thank you to our friends
over at liquid IV you know how much I
love liquid IV what is it liquid IV it's
the fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated now look I run a little hot
okay I'm Sicilian I've got kind of oily
skin so I would need a liquid IV to stay
hydrated anyway athletes love liquid IV
because it just helps you hydrate two to
three times faster and more efficiently
than water alone with an added bonus of
vitamin C b3 b5 beet well
and b6 I'm not the most athletic guy
okay closest I come to playing a sport
is poker it's maybe I smoke a cigar
during that so I can exercise my lungs
but the other thing that liquid IV is
very good for is if maybe you go out you
have a couple adult beverages have a
couple Coca Cola's with the boys
sometimes the next morning you don't
feel so well your head kind of hurts a
little bit you're dehydrated so if I'm
going to engage in a little reasonable
behavior like that you know stay out a
little too late I will have a liquid IV
it's amazing it works so incredibly well
I love it's just a little powder you
just take it out you put the powder in
the water
it tastes very good unlike some of these
other brands that don't taste that good
you drink it you feel much more hydrated
let's leave it at that it's
fastest-growing wellness brand you can
find them everywhere even at Costco you
can find their hydration multiplied or
sold at all Costco's nation-wide
liquid IV provides the same hydration as
drinking two to three bottles of water I
love it right now my listeners get 25%
off at liquid IV dot-com when you use my
code Knowles Ken wles at check app
that's 25% off anything you order on
liquid IVs website go to liquid IV com
enter my promo code Knowles to get your
savings and start getting better
hydration liquid IV dot-com promo code
Knowles canna wles
don't wait start properly hydrating
today new information hunter Biden the
company that he was on the board of
pushed the Obama administration to end
the corruption investigation in 2016 a a
representative from burries m'a the
energy company sought to meet with the
undersecretary of state Catherine
Novelli to discuss allegations of
corruption and to maybe discuss a way
out of it this is according to the
award-winning investigative journalist
John Solomon has happened in February
2016 there were emails between the State
Department officials which stated this
is between State Department officials
for our conversation karen tramonto no
of Bluestar strategies requests in a
meeting to discuss with undersecretary
Novelli remarks alleging buries me
of corruption she noted that two
high-profile US citizens are affiliated
with the company including hunter Biden
as a board member
Tremonti know would like to talk with
undersecretary Novelli about getting a
better understanding about how the u.s.
came to the determination that the
company is corrupt so there's a lot here
first of all we know that the State
Department considered this company
corrupt they're saying it right here on
the memos we know that hunter Biden's
presence on the board was being used by
the company to get out of this
corruption investigation and skirt the
rules that's also in the email and yet
the media are going to lie to us and say
there's no evidence there's no big deal
this is it this is the evidence we have
it right here in black and white but
some people aren't going to believe what
they see with their own eyes they're
gonna believe the narratives crafted by
the mainstream media which is a very bad
idea that will mislead you that will
force you to believe fantasies like the
fantasy that Jeffrey Epstein killed
himself we will get to why the ex
evangelical pastors don't understand the
evangelical movement we will get to
Christian support of President Trump
we'll get to homelessness we'll get to a
whole lot more fake news narratives but
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube you know the
founder and leader of Isis is dead
thanks to America's goodest dog so you
can now get the shirt that'll turn even
the most hardcore cat fans into dog
lovers that shirt is the zero bark 30
shirt let's see if here zero bark 30
available now at the Daily wire Amazon
store is one of my favorite shirts we've
ever made a huge fan of it so head on
over there get your zero barked 30 shirt
and we will just keep the pun apparel
coming daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
so an ex evangelical pastor is coming
out and saying that evangelicals who
support Trump are humiliating themselves
embarrassing themselves they are
damaging the gospel what this guy is
doing Joshua Harris is one of my least
favorite behaviors in politics which is
when people who are not in a particular
movement not in a particular mindset not
in a particular religion start
criticizing the people who are in that
organization for failing to live up to
their own standards usually without any
basis in reality whatsoever
here is X evangelical Joshua Harris's
claim sounds like you think the church
has made a massive mistake by becoming
so identified with President Trump I
think it's saying incredibly damaging to
the gospel and to the church and you
give advice you still give advice they
give advice how do they know that what
should they do I don't think it's gonna
end well
and I think you know you look back at
you look back at the Old Testament and
the relationship between the prophets
and really bad leaders and kings and
oftentimes it was it's not something you
unwind because it's it's actually in the
scriptures presented as God's judgment
on the false religion of the day you
think Christians today who are embracing
President Trump are due for a judgment I
think it is the judgment I think it is
part of the judgment to have a leader
like Trump I think is in itself part of
of the indictment that that this is the
leader that you want and maybe deserve
that represents a lot of who you are
what what verbal gobbledygook is that
obviously this man is very confused so
let's try to clear up some of the
confusion he says that conservatives
supporting Trump is damaging to the
gospel
you cannot damage the gospel Christ
conquered death on the cross and rose
from the dead three days later you can't
damage that as CS Lewis pointed out an
atheist can no more diminish God's glory
than a lunatic can diminish the son by
writing darkness on the walls of his
cell can't damage the gospel you can
engage in heresy you can disbelieve you
can turn away from God you can't damage
the gospel the gospel happened it's done
our redeemer lives then he says that the
people who voted for Donald Trump are
calling judgment down upon them that's
just rude let's just remind people what
it means to vote for Donald Trump he had
two choices in 2016 a woman who was
campaigning on killing a million babies
a year and taking all away all of your
constitutional rights and taking away
your religious liberty and Trump a guy
who said he wouldn't do those things and
would protect life and would protect
religious liberty we knew how wicked
Hillary Clinton was we weren't quite
sure how wicked Donald Trump was we knew
that he lived a sort of colorful life
and was a very broken man as are we all
but those were the choices kill a
million babies a year take away your
constitutional rights take away your
religious liberty protect life keep your
religious liberty keep your rights maybe
that's not a hard choice that's not a
wrong choice that's not an evil choice
that's not calling down judgment the
right choice was to vote for Trump and
if this guy is upset about that because
he didn't do that or he thought Trump
would be worse than he is or whatever
okay fine I get it it was a difficult
choice in so much as Trump is such a
weird political candidate that it
allowed people to become confused I get
it that's fine but that was the right
choice and then you know it's the right
choice because he's asked by
interviewer what judgment is being
called down upon people for this and the
guy says III know I don't know it's
we'll have to see it's not gonna end
well the judgement is having Trump
president so now he's saying that the
judgement is gonna be that people get
what they asked for okay if this is the
judgment not so bad
could things be better in the country
sure or things a lot better than they
would have been under President Clinton
yeah a lot better in every way okay
that's fine judgment he's obviously very
confused he isn't seeing moral questions
very clearly and perhaps that has
something to do with the fact that he's
made a complete disaster of his own life
as he explains in the same interview as
a very young man you wrote a book that
sold a million copies yeah it was called
I kiss dating goodbye and that got a lot
of attention because it was a radical
idea we shouldn't just not have sex we
should stop dating because dating is
leading to us making these mistakes so
the first time because your wife was at
the altar yeah I got married about a
year and a half after that book was
released and then dove into being a
pastor and pastored a church for for 17
years I was a pastor there and then this
summer you went on Instagram and said
essentially I don't believe mmm by all
the measurements that I have for
defining a Christian I'm not a Christian
what do you mean by that I was really
just trying to be honest about the fact
that all the ways that I had defined
faith and Christianity that I was no
longer choosing to live according to
those most significantly the decision
that my wife and I made to end our
marriage
some people were angry a lot of people
are angry understandably understandably
at least he has a little self-awareness
there because
what he's doing is it's not just Joshua
Harris who does this a lot of people do
this a lot you will always hear every
single day if you go on the internet you
will hear atheists criticizing
Christians for supporting Donald Trump
because they say this is unchristian
these are people who know nothing about
Christianity or who at the very least
are extraordinarily confused about
Christianity who don't believe in
Christianity who don't think
Christianity is true or good assailing
people who do believe Christianity is
true or good and who know much more
about Christianity than they do for
supporting Donald Trump because they say
it's on Christian how about like one
ounce of humility if you don't it's not
a big deal if you don't understand
something all of us don't understand
most things but just a little humility
instead of saying you're a terrible
Christian because you do something that
I don't quite understand
and you also profess a faith that I
don't understand and don't believe in
and don't think is good but you're bad
for that reason for some for some reason
how about a little humility I hear this
there's a guy John Fugelsang who I sort
of like he's a liberal radio guy who
refers to people who support Donald
Trump as fake Christians john fugelsang
knows absolutely nothing about
christianity he knows actually less than
nothing because he knows a very little
bit and a little learning is a dangerous
thing so for instance he thinks that the
Scriptures defend abortion and this is
because there's one translation of one
verse out of context of the book of
numbers that could be misinterpreted to
refer to a miscarriage rather than
infertility one translation among
zillions of translations of the Bible
and he'll twist that and say that
everybody who supports Trump is a bad
Christian that isn't true before you
cast aspersions like that you should
just have the intellectual humility and
the curiosity to learn something
yourself what Joshua Harris says there
is a lot of people are upset at him
because he's left the church he's left
his wife he's left his faith and he made
himself out to be this great evangelical
Christian leader this guy always had
profound theological errors in what he
was peddling like very deep theological
errors he was the guy who came up with
the idea that you shouldn't date he says
how I kissed dating goodbye and created
this whole purity culture that is a
historical and deeply misunderstands the
nature of the faith and then surprise
surprise he ran into troubles with his
faith because his version of it was
unsatisfactory to him was insufficient
was inadequate now he's left the faith
and people are rightly angry because
he's causing scandal a scandal is not
just when a politician gets caught with
a secretary a scandal is when you lead
people away by your example because
you've done something wrong this is one
of my great incentives not to sin is I
have no I'm not no problem but I could
easily be tempted to sin if it were just
involving me and then you know I go to
confession and I repent of it and I'm
very sorry and I go back to living of my
life but it doesn't just involve you
especially if you make yourself a public
persona like Joshua Harris did because
by your example you could lead people
away from the truth and lead people away
from the faith and that's a very bad
thing so I'm glad that he has that that
slight awareness but then he immediately
turns it around and says and by the way
if you vote for Trump you're a terrible
person and destroying Christianity hey
buddy you left your church you left your
wife you left your faith
I'm not even attacking you for it
obviously you've got some deep confusion
and a lot of suffering going on and you
need to figure your life out but maybe
you're not the best guy to lecture all
of us on Christianity maybe you're not
the best guy to lecture all of us on I
don't live your life okay you did that
for your entire life and then it didn't
work out for you and you let a lot of
people down a lot of bad paths they
step back a little bit same thing with
the media when we were talking about all
day the mainstream media which lied to
us all the time which are caught in
scandal actual scandal because they're
the ones who purport to tell the truth
and they are caught covering up the
truth and spreading lies which destroys
our faith in the mainstream media
destroys our faith in these institutions
that we should be able to trust and
leads us to believe internet memes
because the internet memes are truer
than the mainstream media those guys
have the audacity to say democracy dies
in darkness Washington Post facts first
CNN we just report the facts we're
defending them no you're not you're not
which is fine you're going through a
period of intense corruption sort your
affairs get your house in order before
you all lecture us I just have no
patience for it anymore
I have nope Eric Garcetti the mayor of
my city I live in tent city USA I live
in Los Angeles I was on a news program
the other day on the Fox channel here
and Eric Garcetti had just gone on the
show and he was asked by the host of the
show Alex Michaelson what are you doing
about homeless homelessness under mayor
Garcetti is tenure homelessness has
increased dramatically it has
skyrocketed in just one year 2017 to
2018 homelessness increased in LA County
by 13% and then in LA City by 16% 16% in
one year and Garcetti says with a
straight face there's no question LA is
the model for dealing with homelessness
how can you say that how can you
Gaslight us all like that just a look if
Eric or City came out there and said hey
homelessness is a really hard problem
we're having a lot of trouble with it
we're being hampered by state and county
regulations it's just we're working on
it we're trying to get more cops on the
beat to bring people in and we're gonna
do our best and make it happen
at least then we could respect the guy
but he can't do that and this actually
this story does tie in with another
story we're going to
tomorrow because it's it's just that
that gas lighting is so offensive to all
of us it leads you to to distrust all of
your institutions that is the real
scandal because I actually as much as I
love the means as much as I love that
Epstein didn't kill himself as much as I
love all the Wild West of information
that we have now I actually would prefer
to live in a country where we can have
some faith in our institutions where we
can trust the media to not lie to us
every single night where we can trust
the government not to spy on its own
citizens and to spy on rival
presidential campaigns like the Obama
administration obviously did I would
like to live in a government where the
courts support the rule of law and
defend our Constitution where half of
the country didn't hate itself where
half of the country didn't protest the
American flag I would rather live in
that country because then we could talk
about politics less you know CS Lewis to
bring him up again had a line on this
REE said a country that doesn't talk
about politics at all is in danger of
dying because obviously Lewis wrote it
more eloquently than me but I'm
paraphrasing it's in danger of dying
because in the same way a sick person
who doesn't pay attention to what's
going on with his health could die as
well but a country that spends all of
its time talking about politics
countries such as ours where we can't
trust our institutions where we don't
believe anything that the mainstream
media or the establishment are telling
us a country that spends all its time
talking about politics is already so
thoroughly sick the sickness is already
through it then it's on the verge of
being killed already much like Jeffrey
Epstein who did not kill himself that's
our show I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bori
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is nick Chien the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]